[Aplausos]
[Música]
así
y
[Música]
ya mejor
si quieres seguirme
[Música]
bien
llorando
me parece
[Música]
no avanza
[Aplausos]
[Música]
qué peso
y
[Música]
cuando era muy pequeño
más o menos 11 años 12 se me presentó
una cosa que me marcó mucho en mi vida
una historia que me sucedió iba al
colegio
en mi barrio en florencio varela
y me acuerdo que había una prueba que el
profesor de música nos pedía en ese
momento yo estaba muy conectado con la
música pero no desde la forma
y que enseñaban quizás en un colegio
donde enseñaban canciones y demás
entonces ya estaba conectado pero medio
desconectado de de esta manera de
aprender música entonces un día el profe
pide que podamos tocar lo que sabíamos
entonces yo no tenía ninguna guitarra y
le pedí a uno de mis amigos que me dé
una
cuando le doy a cuando me da la guitarra
me pongo así de esta forma la guitarra
para tocar antes tocaba quizás más
horizontal entonces el profesor me dijo
no no nos dice empezamos mal dice vos no
puedes tocar así porque yo enseño de
otra forma
a mí no ven no me vengas con cosas raras
media
entonces le digo bueno pero por lo menos
déjame tocar
entonces me dice bueno mira vas a tocar
pero vos estás desaprobados porque mira
me gusta que los chicos aprendan de la
forma que quiera pues entonces con el
ánimo tan alto que me dejó a mí eso
me puse a tocar
entonces cuando termino de tocar el
profesor
toma el cuaderno el libro de actas lo
cierra y se va del salón entonces a los
cinco minutos nosotros nos quedamos
atónitos medios sorprendidos ya los
cinco minutos viene la directora del
colegio y me dice nahuel quería contarte
que el profesor de música no supo qué
hacer con tu caso y renunció al cargo
entonces
entonces la primera experiencia con la
música fue bastante fuerte para mí digo
que hago
pero allí entendí
quizás la convicción y la emoción de
hacer música de la forma que uno lo
sienta no lo quiera es lo más importante
no desde siempre que yo tengo una
relación muy fuerte con la música
soy hijo de músicos y la música ha hecho
muchas cosas en mí lo más importante que
me dio es la libertad no en la música yo
me siento libre me siento pleno me
siento agradecido a la vida de dios por
darme una forma de expresarme
con esta yo soy una persona sencilla
transparente pero creo que en la música
quizás se ve quizás más mi honestidad
entonces desde siempre fue una
experiencia muy grande la música pasé
por muchas etapas una etapa muy fuerte
fue cuando decidí tocar en la calle a
los 16 años sentía que tenía que
dedicarme a la música y no tenía donde
tocar entonces les dije a mis padres
quiero tocar en la calle en la peatonal
entonces fui a tocar a la peatonal
florida de buenos aires y ahí la verdad
que me sentí útil me sentí tranquilo
porque mis padres sabían que algo es que
algo iba a ser mi vida entonces ellos se
podían ir tranquilos de este mundo
sabiendo que la música me acompañaba
y la música me dio todo me dio la
intuición me dio lo espontáneo me dio la
emoción
y más allá de que la música a veces uno
la toma como virtuosismo como prolijidad
como que todo tiene que salir bien creo
que la emoción es lo que abunda y es lo
más importante para mí y eso me ha dado
la seguridad la libertad que yo hoy
puedo expresar
a través de las canciones
creo que en todos los caminos en todos
los caminos que vivimos y que
transitamos siempre hay cosas que
superar siempre todo el tiempo yo
recuerdo cuando era chico
kim
un problema fuerte que sentía que tenía
era que me sentía solo me sentía
distinto iba al colegio y me sentaba
solo no tenía amigos entonces yo pensaba
que algo estaba haciendo mal y decía por
qué estoy tan solo me podía escuchar
música por ejemplo en los en los recreos
del colegio de los chicos escuchan
música este
y las cosas que yo escuchaba eran
totalmente distintas entonces yo me
sentía distinto al mismo tiempo cuando
tocaba la guitarra de esta manera
sentía que todos me miraban todos
miraban la técnica miraba la forma de
tocar y yo hacía tan mal está esto
porque estará mal y yo sentía que había
prejuicios en el medio prejuicios quizás
de los demás
por ahora y no tener la confianza en mí
por el hecho de no ver y no saber cómo
tratar menos saber que lo que podía
hacer pero yo siempre tuve la convicción
muy adelante la bandera de la convicción
y
y de la necesidad de hacer algo por mí
de hacer en este caso música y ser una
persona sencilla fue lo que me hizo ver
las cosas de otra manera y desde ese
momento
y quiso
puede transformar gracias a la música
que yo creo que lo hace todo por mí
puede transformar un problema que tenía
en una solución en una forma de
justamente desde de vivirlo de otra
manera a veces uno se enfoca en el
problema
y no se puede enfocar en cómo resolverlo
entonces a mí me parece que la confianza
que nosotros tengamos en nosotros mismos
justamente es lo más importante cuando
nosotros decimos
y las cosas me salen mal porque porque
la vida no me da una posibilidad yo creo
que la voluntad
funciona a través de la iniciativa de
uno
si yo me quedo en mi casa sin saber qué
hacer no podría tener esta experiencia
de dar esta charla para ustedes ni de ni
de compartir con un montón de personas
todo el tiempo no podría porque yo no
estoy haciendo nada sin embargo siento
que la música a mí
ha hecho todo me ha dado mucha libertad
y la voluntad yo creo que también va de
la mano con lo que uno atrae
entonces
siento que la confianza en nosotros
mismos es lo más importante
y siempre tenemos la posibilidad de
transformar
las cosas a veces son o se enfocan lo
que no tienen entonces que podría decir
yo no yo la verdad que no tengo
posibilidades porque bueno al no ver
obviamente que esto más difícil y demás
hay muchas personas que conozco incluso
familias que a veces se cuesta tratar
con
con estos estos temas que son mundiales
a veces desde ese lugar aparecen los
prejuicios aparece la ignorancia como
trató una persona entonces a mí me
parece que la bandera la tenemos que
llevar nosotros la bandera de la
confianza de poder resolver un problema
sobre todo de
[Música]
de sentirse libre con lo que uno quiere
hacer no a veces uno escucha muchas
voces a veces
está pensando en la aprobación del otro
no cuando uno hace algo
después el mira a su papá su mamá su
amigo y te gustó
y si te dicen que no te frustras
y si te dicen que si seguís adelante
entonces qué pasa uno pasa a depender de
lo que digan los demás eso no tiene que
pasar yo creo que nosotros tenemos
la suficiente las suficientes
herramientas para poder transformar las
cosas quizás si yo me quedaba con lo que
me dijo este profesor en su momento no
podría haber hecho nada
por qué
la música
justamente es universal las expresiones
con la música son todas válidas
y me parece que lo importante es poder
conectar con lo imprescindible lo
imprescindible en mi vida en la música
es lo emocional no es el poder seguir
hacia adelante y qué pasa yo puedo tener
muchas dificultades en el camino
todos tenemos dificultades no hay
crecimiento sin dolor no podemos decir
no este a mí me va bien yo soy
plenamente feliz no a mí no a mí nunca
me pasó nada a nosotros nos tienen que
pasar cosas nos deben pasar cosas
tenemos que sufrir a veces
por amor tenemos que sufrir por
y no poder hacer lo que uno quiere
tenemos que aprender de eso y yo creo
que si uno puede superarse
aparece lo lindo la confianza la emoción
la pasión uno tiene que tener pasión por
lo que hacen entonces
como sé que acá somos muchos jóvenes
a todos ustedes les digo y también me
digo a mí
miremos hacia adelante y tengamos la
convicción de ser alguien en la vida
hacer algo poder aprovechar poder
aprender poder admirar más saben qué
lindo que es admirar otros músicos poder
disfrutarlos poder aprender
mirarse al espejo mirarse al espejo a
todo el tiempo poder reconocer qué es lo
que tenemos que mejorar qué es lo que
tenemos que vivir qué es lo que está
bien también
uno para adentro tiene que pensar que el
camino es éste yo sé que mi camino es la
música yo lo sé
pero siempre tengo la necesidad de
seguir aprendiendo y de seguir creciendo
y la forma es compartirlo con ustedes
esta charla
que me toca darla por primera vez a mí
también me deja cosas me deja enseñanzas
no quedarse con la frustración tener la
convicción adelante
tomar una decisión fuerte cuando uno
toma una decisión y le dice que sí a
algo también le está diciendo que no a
otra cosa entonces confiemos en lo que
tenemos
agradezcamos también el aprender del
dolor de la angustia de las emociones
y todo depende de nosotros todos
absolutamente depende de nosotros y en
nosotros está el poder transformar las
diferentes cosas que nos vayan pasando y
todo depende de la confianza que nos
tengamos a nosotros mismos eso para mí
es lo más importante
quería agradecerles infinitamente por
por escuchar palabras por
por haber visto mi historia
y
como lo más importante para mí es la
música y lo que más me gusta es la
música
quería cerrar también esta charla con
una canción para unirnos entre todos y
poder cantar desde nuestro corazón
y
[Música]
cambia lo superficial cambia también lo
profundo cambia el modo de pensar cambia
todo
en este mundo cambia el clima con los
años cambia el pastor y su rebaño yo así
como todo con
que yo camino es extraño
[Música]
d
un día más
[Música]
al caminar
como todo cambia que yo camino
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y no todos
[Aplausos]
todo
y a todo cambiar
pero no de formas
[Música]
dolor
lo que yo sé tendrá que cambiar mañana
yo soy
en esta tierra
[Aplausos]
[Música]
nosotros
cambia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a
[Música]
su camino
[Aplausos]
[Música]
gracias
[Aplausos]